foreign
Gage kicks us off in Sacramento Gage
welcome to the show
hi thank you how you guys doing today
we're doing great how are you
I'm doing well all right so I had a
quick question
um I have about twenty thousand dollars
worth of credit card debt right now I'm
just turned 25
um I also still owe about 9 000 on my
car what I'm calling about is I'm
currently in the process of getting into
a flight school in San Diego that's
going to be taken up about two years of
my time uh full-time schooling so I'm
curious uh what's the best way to go
about this debt uh I've talked to some
people who has recommended like a
bankruptcy to just wipe the Slate clean
so once I get a career I'm not still
drowning in that debt I just kind of
wanted to get you guys opinion and well
who is some people who did you talk to
uh probably not the smartest people I
don't have a ton of financially uh
literate friends oh it is your friends
like us broke people for financial
advice and they gave it to you declare
bankruptcy Clean Slate it's going to
help your career
yeah I didn't think it sounds that smart
all that smart you knew you knew that
was bad advice I mean you're here
calling us so I'm glad you didn't make
that move yet because it's absolutely
not the move you should be making
thank you what's your income
uh making about 48 per year
will that change with flight school
um so while I'm in flight school I don't
believe I'll be making the income uh
it's the school is going to be 100
accredited uh by the VA so okay so
you're not paying a dime for the school
no wow that's incredible flight school
is expensive
yeah it is it is not cheap
okay so school's covered how are you
going to pay for the bills do you have
any bills at that point
are they covering room and board a few
small bills that could be paid with um
you know just Uber Lyft doordash things
like that I was kind of figuring like
free time yeah are you able to work
full-time
uh so I'm not sure exactly what the the
schedule will look like I currently
worked full-time I've worked full time
since I was 17. I just turned 25 so okay
how long till flight school starts
I'm planning on starting in January so
uh about five months okay that's good my
question is can we clean this debt up in
five months you think you could do that
I believe so like I said I just I've
kind of how I've grown up I haven't
grown up around a lot of financially
literate people so I don't really know
the steps to start taking I just found
uh Dave Ramsey a couple weeks ago I've
been watching you know the baby steps
and watching a lot of his content and uh
just trying to get ahead here well we
can help you with the steps um just a
quick question are you gonna have a
housing allowance once you start
doing that flight school for the VA yeah
so that's uh that's still in the process
I'm not 100 sure yet okay if I'm not
then I'm I'll 100 have to have to find
you know a real steady source of income
but I mean I'm not too worried about
that I don't have any problem you know
finding a job or working do you have any
money
I don't I've been living paycheck to
paycheck for the past few years now and
uh most of that is all my fault just
making dumb decisions but uh I want to
start getting ahead and getting things
together
self-awareness is the first step so I'm
proud of you for even owning that
instead of just blaming everything and
everyone else for the problems that
tells me you're going to get out of this
thing so what is the car this was uh
pretty much just me
you said what is the car worth yeah
uh I believe they're blue books I
probably looked it up a couple months
ago somewhere around ten five okay so
I'm just thinking if you really wanted
to get out I want you out of debt by
flight school so that you have a life
and you know you can work to pay the
bills but you're not trying to also
tackle all this debt and you've got some
time you've got five months to really go
hard at this thing and work extra and do
the Uber and lift on top of your
full-time job and if you threw you know
five or six k a month of this thing it's
gone so the question is what is that Gap
to where we need what we need to make to
get five or six k a month thrown at the
debt
yeah
um because right now what's your
take-home pay
my take-home pay uh right around 2000
per check
and I get paid bi-weekly okay
a month
and uh obviously you got to make your
debt payments you have rent right now
yes but my rent is very cheap how cheap
uh I'm currently paying about 600 a
month okay good that is cheap for
Sacramento I was like cheap for
Californians it's very different like
it's only three grand a month that's
cheap no good job yeah no yeah that's
great like I said I have been kind of a
fool with my money so I need to start
getting that I mean at the end of the
day when it comes to paint wanting to
pay off debt it's a pretty simple
equation you know we're trying to uh
lower our expenses as much as possible
while simultaneously increasing our
income as much as possible in order to
have as much money as possible to throw
out this debt so that's what you're
looking to do that should be the uh the
mindset that you filter all of your
choices through for the next five months
is is this going to bring my expenses
down or is this going to drive my income
up and so that's that's the idea here
for the next five months and then once
you get into flight school you're going
to kind of have to evaluate your
situation find out what your time is
going to be like find out if you're
getting a home allowance because if you
are that's great that frees up some
money find out how much you're going to
be able to work so you've kind of got
two equations that you're looking at one
is the the now and the current and the
next one is here in the future what
that's going to look like with your new
um obligations in Flight School what's
your car payment
uh my car payment 256 per month okay
it may not be worth selling the car
because I think you can pay it off
pretty quickly and you'd have to go
around and buy something else anyways
and you don't have any money to do that
so I would attack that car payment first
I mean I know you got the credit card
debt are those multiple cards
uh it's two cards yes so what's the
lowest the majority of the amount is on
one card and then uh about like a
thousand is on the other card okay and
then it's making the Opera the the
choice also to say I'm not using credit
cards anymore so if you haven't yet cut
up these credit cards make sure you've
cut those up once they're paid off close
out
yeah I haven't used a credit card in in
like some months now okay great so
you've learned your lesson there never
to go back again very good all right so
I'm gonna gift you one year Financial
based University and one year of every
dollar premium to help you on this
journey making a plan for every one of
those dollars creating that margin
seeing the progress learning the steps
because you said you're new to all this
stuff so that is my gift to you uh not
only as a veteran but someone who's new
to this program and we're thankful for
you Gage so hang on the line we'll gift
that to you